all right guys you ready to do this
sound check testing one two three
testing let's do it so what are we going
to talk about in 15 years of ministry
we've never done anything like this
details drop next week stay
tuned find out on this episode of LED
live
warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised it started with an
addiction to masturbation um that's
where it really started at what age at
age five the responsibility is on both
sides like as as much as the church has
dropped the ball as someone in the
lifestyle who is wanting to come out is
approaching the church there's all these
preconceived ideas and doubts and fears
there I can imagine that people who are
specifically raised Christians who pray
that prayer God please take it away and
God doesn't from you guys' experience
how do you deal with that yeah I think
that the both both parents should um
take interest in their child if they
have an interest in in in things that
seem to be more feminine but make sure
that that child understands the
specialness of being the gender that God
created them to
[Music]
be welcome to LED live it's a show where
we use the Light of Christ to expose the
darkness found in media and our called
you today and I'd like to welcome some
uh new faces to the show today we have
uh Wayne Wayne Blakeley he is the uh
director of know his love Ministries
thank you so much for being on great to
be here thank and we have Topher Wayne
is going to introduce uh Topher in a
little bit here but thank you for for
coming on the show as well you're
welcome and of course hey denique woohoo
how are you doing I'm good how are you
doing well doing well and um and and I'm
Kendy we're team members of Little Light
Studios but you know we're getting uh to
the end of uh pride month here and
there's a lot of conversations happening
there's a lot of campaigns and agendas
and um uh I don't I don't think it's
something that the church should shy
away from because what is the church
made up of people yeah people dealing
with a lot of different things not just
exclusively talking about sexuality but
in general and so uh that's what I
believe is a blessing of this show and
we don't back away from tough
conversations or just really practical
conversations and so today we're going
to be discussing uh the lifestyle
choices that people make especially in
relation to the Christian faith or the
Christian walk or maybe even how the
church is is addressing uh the the topic
of of sexuality or lifestyle choices and
so uh Wayne I will turn things over to
you and I thank you for for the work
that you're doing in in raising
awareness in this area oh thanks Kandy
it's it's a a challenge for sure uh but
I thought that it would be important um
since it is um pride month to have this
discussion and bring it to some people's
attention
um there is a lot um going on today as
it relates to social declarations and
identity um Pride mon has put an
emphasis um on the fact that the LGBT
acronym is you know continually
growing and I believe that the LGBT
narrative is kind of edging out some
constitutional rights as it relates to
religious freedom and um just simply the
right to choose it's interesting that
the LGBT community has that much
power um our community or I mean our
country um and government's Roots were
founded with Christian principles um you
you even take the term you know marriage
you know it it came out of the Bible so
it's it's always interesting to me how
where we arrived at you know gay
marriage but I think that um pride month
is actually an opportunity to explore
what Jesus has to offer and the identity
that he offers to each one of us and um
to be able to follow him if you choose
and let me just point out that choice is
something in an xgay Ministry that I
always want to emphasize because God is
a god of invitation and not a god of
force absolutely um a number of our of
viewers are familiar with my particular
testimony I've I've been here you know
off and on over the last couple of years
but you know I'll recap a little bit
that I grew up Christian um I think that
there are many different causes for um
someone's maybe turning out to be
LGBT I I now say that it used to be
rather organic um it could
be a bonding issue with a parent it
could be a prenatal influence as it was
in my life and postnatal abuse my arm
was busted what do you mean by prenatal
influences uh the thought patterns in
the psychological condition of the birth
mother um during her pregnancy and
science has shown that you know during
the third triester that the influence of
her whatever's going on in her life
might have some kind of an effect on
what the child ends up
choosing not that necessarily that you
were scientifically born gay but that
the there's an influence there that
would set you up well for instance I'll
give you an example my birth mother was
adamant throughout her pregnancy and
particularly towards the end that she
was only going to give birth to a girl
not a boy right and then postnatally she
was angry and upset that she'd given
birth to a boy so she busted my arm in
two different places before I was 2
years old and so now I'm running around
dressing like a little girl because I'm
figuring that that's how I'm going to
get the love of my mother I mean that's
really what had happened and so just to
make the distinction I'm sorry then what
is the difference when someone says Born
This Way versus what you just described
why why is there a difference what is
because because it's not there
genetically okay so there's no science
you know John Hopkins has done multiple
studies and even their most recent study
has shown there still is no gay gene but
when we look at influences and I think
that's why and I'm probably getting
ahead of myself but that's why I think
that Christian psychology is rather
important too uh because when you look
at trauma and the effects of trauma most
pastors are not equipped to deal with
that and we need we should we should all
have someone to go and talk to and
that's why I think that our human rights
are really important today and that the
American Psychological associ
Association shouldn't be the one that
gets to say you can you know you can do
this and you can't do that as it relates
to the realm of
Christianity um so yeah I I you know as
plac I was adopted you know after the
abuse had taken place I was adopted by
an aunt and
uncle and I was already shaped and uh
influenced to be more of a little girl
and so you know I'm I'm you know playing
with scarves and dresses and all these
kinds of things by the time I enter into
school in first grade I I start being
teased and bullied and harassed and
obviously you know and and my cousin
which became my brother who was 7 years
older than me um he certainly wasn't
very proud of the fact that he had you
know this little eminite boy you know in
his household that was you know
certainly wreaking
havoc but um my parents you know aunt
and uncle but I would call them my
parents now they were very um patient
with
me they they had lots of questions they
were certainly beginning to pray and ask
God you know help us out here cuz we
don't really know what's going on
whereas today you know you have a whole
different set of circumstances and
scenarios in in family environments
today and now kids are really calling
the shots or influencing the parents to
do things their way instead of you know
realizing they might just be going
through a phase
thankfully I did survive those 12 years
of teasing bullying and harassment and
you know by the time I was 18 19 18
years old I was I was perfectly happy
that I was male I'd come to the realize
that you know sort of what had taken
place the abuse and uh the social stigma
around homosexuality and at the age of
18 um I uh made a decision to walk into
the LGBT community I was influenced by
somebody who invited me in um told me
that I was gay and I lived there for 40
years okay but you said you got to to
the point where you were accepting of
your gender and and and all that was
that through as a result of therapy or
self-reflection interestingly enough it
was the LGBT community that gave me the
affirmation okay because wow would
someone get that today
right ex that's probably a whole another
thing but because see men were
appreciating men for being men right now
it doesn't necessarily go the same way
for female because the because of the
abuse that is sometimes done with
females they don't want to appear to be
a female because they feel like they're
weak yes and that that it would draw
more attacks from overpowering men and
so they often will seek to look like a
man so that a guy doesn't want to lay
his hands on her but then that would
become attractive to another female so
it's more of an emotional thing with
them whereas for men I believe it's much
more of a sexual thing when did it
become more normalized to become
transgender instead of staying men right
well you know I don't think that
affirmation is now being challenged yeah
well in my mind the so yes we used to
have drag queens and all in the bars and
stuff and it was more
entertainment but for the whole
transgender thing it was kind of you
know very quiet and very subdued even
though there was gender dysphoria there
which I also
experienced culturally there was n and
socially there wasn't a big promoting of
that until Caitlyn Jenner and when
Caitlyn Jenner took place that became a
celebrity status and it got lots of
publicity and being on the front of
Vogue and airbrushed and looking like oh
you know maybe those feelings inside of
me maybe they really are real and I can
go this way and the popularity and and
now they had a champion for their cause
and so people were coming out of the
woodwork and ident if Ying as trans and
and then you know it was even after that
that all the trans surgeries and all all
of that became very popular I believe
after the interesting power and
influence of media yeah that's why we
have this channel yeah okay so you're
saying um at 18 yeah so 18 you know I
get influenced and by somebody who I was
working with uh that was gay and and who
influenced me to go to my first gay bar
and suddenly guys were wanting to get to
know me and that certainly wasn't my
experience as a younger child because
you know I wasn't sports-minded or
anything and they didn't want anything
to do with me and so guys had become
somewhat the mystery and and that became
my attraction the more um the more
heterosexual like the guy the more draw
and
so uh you know I lived in male
prostitution for 12 years and in part of
that was the addiction for me was to my
my advertising and all wasn't too much
the LGBT community as it was to the
heterosexual Community because I was
looking
for a man I wasn't I wasn't looking
really for somebody identifying as gay I
really wanted the conquest of that
heterosexual and that kept that business
going on because it was like a feather
in my cap to have you know potentially
heterosexual men that were coming and
receiving erotic massages whole another
that seems like a a Common Thread with I
think a lot of um people that you know
in the community that they want to that
conquest of getting a straight man yes
yes exactly and and it the thing that
you don't feel confident in yourself
really becomes the attraction and that
and then within that when the when you
hook up with someone like that and the
intimate relationship is good and then
all of a sudden you go oh I think I'm in
love and so it's it's a whole backwards
way of getting there you know because
yes emotions are involved and all but
guys tend to put the sex before the
before the actual relationship where
with women they more emotionally go at
something before it's
eroticized why would you say the
influence of the group that you got into
at 18 what was it that was Stronger
there than than your home which was an
even better experience than your initial
upbringing the first two years the
affirmation that came from being with a
masculine man and the acceptance is what
would keep me as compared to your
uncle cuz you said you you yeah so my my
when my my so my uncle or what I would
refer to as my dad he was constantly
trying to get me to play with trucks to
be good in sports and to do all these
things whereas my forte was really
Floral Design interior design and
fashion and those kinds of things and
those were not masculine things can I
challenge you a little bit sure I'm
wondering uh did those interests come
from the original influence or was that
something you think was already inside
you cuz I'm thinking of a parent who may
have a child in that situation um maybe
something in the the child's upbringing
has now pushed them to towards a certain
um interest set of interests and now
they're trying to redirect should they
redirect or should they actually affirm
that original influence right I believe
it came from my birth mother's uh
insistence that I was I was to meant to
have been a girl instead of a boy and so
that the prenatal influence and the
postnatal abuse already had me Shaped in
being more female than male that it was
an imposition on me rather than than
something that naturally came about okay
and so the the tactic of your your your
father um you think so he's trying to
get me to be interested in boy things
and I was I was I was not interested I
was not good at it I was not uh
coordinated um so it was more of a
hindrance than actual hope but could you
see the position that he might be in
like oh maybe I don't I shouldn't affirm
you know what is connected really to a
trauma but but how do I push him in the
right direction or how do I connect so
he was making an effort and I believe
that you know because they really did
seek to do all that they could do to
help me mature into being a normal boy
you know we use that word very Loosely
today but but essentially with the
American stigmatism that we put on
gender um because remember I always go
back to you know God created everything
all the beauty and so for me to have an
interest in art or design or or
something like that it that was
perfectly okay it was when it it would
be be it was the influence of
sin and the great controversy that was
at hand that would do the damage and so
you know Satan really goes about trying
to convince you that you're the gender
that that you're not I mean God had
plans for me as a male but the enemy had
plans for me to turn against God's plan
I believe okay so it's not necessarily
that parent should emphasize redirecting
um the the interest so to speak just to
make sure that you can be interested in
art as a boy just understand that yes
your boy God created you as a boy and go
ahead with your interest okay yeah I
think that the both both parents should
um take interest in their child if they
have an interest in in in things that
seem to be more feminine but make sure
that that child understands the
specialness of being the gender that God
created them to be okay I like that yeah
so
I you know like I said I spent 40 years
in this culture and so there's there's a
big experience there a lot of people uh
today that begin to hear something
that's different than what they feel
they want to throw that away you know
they didn't want to Discount you but for
40 years you know I was around thousands
and thousands of men and experiences of
other men and and I can tell you that
Christ was really not the center of of
that community at all you know Stonewall
was where you know the gay rights
movement began and it really began on
priscu and and sex and um and today you
know they try to bring God into the
picture but he's kind of like an
afterthought where if we have listeners
or potential people who are wanting to
know about Christianity and God's Will
and God's plan and how that plan is the
best plan that exists in the center of
this Earth I think those are the things
that are worthy of the disc discussion
today to see you know you know why is
God asking us to live differently than
how we might
feel and so um thankfully I believe that
that prayer is is very powerful because
my parents they never um stopped loving
me they told me that they loved me and
that they cared about me very much that
they didn't have all the answers or
Solutions but they knew that God loved
me too and they weren't going to stop
loving me simply because at the age of
18 that I de you know made a declaration
or came out of the closet as a gay man
and so you know you can imagine for 40
years they witnessed a whole lot of
stuff that they didn't you know did you
come home with boyfriends and all that
or I I did I mean I didn't bring I I was
very conscientious of of of bringing
anyone into the home and they were very
um respectful but they did a couple of
times but then I bring not just
boyfriends but I would bring gay friends
to where my parents lived way out in the
woods on a property and my parents would
still have Worship in the morning they
would uh pray at meals they would invite
us to go to church and when we would
leave their property my my gay friends
who didn't have the same upbringing as I
did would say man your parents are
really
amazing they didn't compromise they
didn't try to do what the LGBT Community
insisted they just were uh parents of of
their faith and they knew that by
reflecting the love of Jesus Christ that
that was to be the the calling card of
Jesus and you know it to some extent it
was working on the hearts and minds of
those that you know my LGBT friends
didn't want to go and confront them with
well you need to do this and you need
need to do that they were seeing that
through my parents that they were very
loving very caring you know very
dedicated people and they could tell
that they loved their
son so one of the greatest Witnesses
yeah those prayers you know the church
didn't come and get me
honestly the prayers of my parents came
and got me because that's awesome you
know I you know in 2009 I found myself
contemplating Jesus again all of my gay
friends had died um to AIDS and I was
not even HIV positive you know when I
should have been because you know I had
so terribly promiscuous I came back to
Christ over a course of time it wasn't
an immediate thing I I've was impressed
that God wanted me to to develop
intimacy with him and I ended up going
to church for three months uh before I
decided that I was going to come back to
go to God and dedicate my life to
him so that's you know just a little
background on me and I found that the um
the church was still very silent on this
topic and I felt that the antidote from
homosexuality was this developing
intimacy with Jesus Christ and so I was
impressed to start talking about it and
that was you that was shortly after my
conversion that was in
2009 but there are other people that
have similar stories and you know we're
very blessed um today uh to have um
Topher here with us and you know Topher
I you know I was put in contact with you
and we had a great conversation and I
could tell that you were comfortable in
talking about your experience yes and
that this is a first time for you to
share this but I know that that's that's
really extremely important to a viewer
who is going through a struggle or who
has lots of questions and also to
parents who are listening and so I would
really like to um to let the those you
know questions kind of you know flood
your mind and and you have the
opportunity to to go ahead and share you
know what it's like for somebody who is
um contemplating Jesus and then also
experiencing same-sex attraction what
has that been like when did it begin you
know tell us your whole story okay okay
so from the beginning um I would say
that it
began let's see so I think it started
towards it started with with an
addiction to masturbation um that's
where it really started at what age at
age five wow and I wasn't abused um in
that way I just discovered it on my own
and so um that was always odd to me but
I knew it was something about it was
like a little bit odd so I wouldn't tell
it to anybody wouldn't share it with
parents or or family members and so I
actually grew up in a family of seven
kids kind of in the middle there and so
but something about masturbation I knew
it was like a little bit taboo from that
age and so I remember even just the
Brokenness of you know feeling a little
bit like rejected at dinner time at age
5 I would go to the back room act like I
was going to the bathroom and then I
would I would masturbate and so that was
kind of odd to me and it just that was
where it was at for a first for the
first few years and then at around I
would say around 7even I discovered like
all of a sudden I had this intense
desire
to to want to be friends with some of
these good-looking boys you know that
were about the same age as me and I just
wanted to I just I would just stare at
them like I remember this one time at a
playground and there was this kid that
was my age and I just sit around the
corner I just looked at him like I
wanted to be him I wanted to be his best
friend and as time went on uh people
started talking you know friends and
family members started talking about uh
you know their attraction to the
opposite gender right and you know like
oh this girl that this girl this and I
realized like something's different
about me I don't have that what is this
and so um that's I say where it started
was was about seven or eight is when I
discovered that that attraction to other
other guys other boys do you do
you reflect or I'm sure you must have
reflected the where did this come from
where did this yeah oh yeah I'm I'm not
a parent U but my heart my my stomach
dropped when he's like five yeah and
you're saying that you you know without
abuse right I remember 7 years old
there's puppy love they're like oh he's
cute but it never it wasn't a deeply
sexual thing to even go to the point of
of touching myself you know what I mean
so then yeah to his to his question you
know where you think that came from so
so the the masturbation and then the
attraction to other boys did were not
did they didn't like Collide until later
on when I went through puberty is that's
when it IT collided okay um so like when
I told the story of me at the playground
staring at this other kid that there
wasn't anything sexual about that but it
was definitely you know very very
interested very want you know what I'm
saying and attraction to him so yeah you
know something I you from a Christian
perspective I believe that you know as
we look at the great controversy between
Jesus and Satan that and because you
know Satan was put out of Heaven you
know Satan was wanting to be higher than
God and he took a third of the angels
with him and so now his plight and his
goal on Earth is to to get in the mind
of a person and and have that person
drawn towards his
ideations even though you know we
wouldn't even think evil maybe you know
predominantly in in that thought process
you know a lot of things for some people
they feel good or they look good or they
smell good but they really end up with
evil but we don't think of it that way
for starters yeah and I think that the
earlier the enemy can grab the attention
of of it of a child than he thinks he
has them for life and so while you've
experienced this relationship with
yourself from from a physiological
standpoint The Next Step would be you
know to draw that attraction could it be
that the enemy would would bring this
attraction about to the same gender yeah
yeah I think it's absolutely fascinating
that you were discovering something like
this still learning about life and
General at that age but could still
identify that something is inherently
wrong with what I'm doing that's
fascinating CU obviously conversations
were being had this was a hidden thing
and in the midst of that even with um uh
you know what what could what I'm trying
to be careful with my words but you know
Devil's influence um there's still God's
presence in that moment of like this is
wrong you know and and that's something
that you know all throughout I I knew
when I acted out in homosexual ways that
it was wrong that's something that never
never left me and that because that's
because of my upbringing you know my
family they were missionaries they were
they're I don't want to talk too much
about them out of respect for them um
but the way that I was raised definitely
affected me and I think aided in my
struggle with homosexuality that being
said um I love my parents and I have a
great relationship with them now um
which is awesome praise the Lord
absolutely but uh yeah going back to
that age that young age because I did
have the best relationship with them I
was not willing to share something like
that and so I isolated Within Myself I I
didn't tell it to anybody and that's the
story of my life for a long time I would
not share with anybody that I knew in my
in my actual life that about my
struggles now sometimes I would you know
share with others and stuff I think it's
interesting or important to acknowledge
that as a you know a a human being
that's been given Life by God that God
has told us throughout his word that
that he puts the spirit of Truth in each
each of us I mean even even in somebody
who murders there's there's still the
ability for the conscience to deal with
the spirit of truth that would bring
about a sense of guilt or that this
maybe isn't right just from an organic
way without even maybe even going to the
Bible yeah and so and then you had the
Christian environment so that helped you
too kind of question like wow am is this
really the route I'm supposed to go by I
don't know what to do because I just
feel this way so tell me tell me um so
puberty
hits so so puberty hits and at that time
you know I started you know ejaculating
and I didn't know what that was and so
then I went to World Book Encyclopedia
to discover what I could because I was
raised in a very conservative household
you have internet no internet no
internet and so um also sadly you know I
wasn't told anything about
I was homeschooled not told anything
about uh sexuality or anything like that
and so other than that you don't touch a
woman blah blah and so with that you
know oh I but you know don't look at
women in that way you know and so went
to the world book looked up as many
terms as I could followed the other
terms that it had went to dictionaries
things like that and then I kind of
discovered that there is this thing
called Gay and that there is you know
these things but I still didn't like
label myself as that or think of myself
in that way I was just like oh this is
something that I struggle with and
sometimes and but I just I just pray and
then and then it's all good that's what
I thought so you never had attractions
for women like at all no I no not at all
I did want as a kid I was like I want to
grow up I want to have a Godly family I
want to have kids I want to have a
family you know all that and uh but as
far as romantic or sexual attraction I
never had any MH yep I can relate to
that yeah MH yeah so so so you what what
happened in did you go to Christian
schools so yes I was homeschooled for up
until High School part of the Year
through high school and then I
personally wanted to go to a very
conservative high school that's what I
requested um went to one of the most
conservative ones that any of you
requested that so that you could you
thought maybe you could grow out of this
yes like me fix myself or I felt safer
there I've heard of that before where
people get into um a heterosexual
relation ship for that reason that they
think that they they can fix themselves
and when that doesn't happen they go
full on into the homosexual lifestyle
and I I definitely relate a little bit
to that um and that I went to very
conservative uh High School boarding
Academy and then after that I went to a
very conservative Bible College as well
so so in that time the as I you know
being similar you know to you I'm I'm
going that the the Mind must just be
going crazy because you're in an
environment and probably even then cuz I
know I'm considerably older than you but
but when you have shower rooms and you
have uh uh you know PE classes and stuff
like well see that's the beauty of a
very conservative school we didn't have
shower rooms there was individual
showers they didn't believe in sports um
wow so for someone like me that you know
hates Sports I was like this is perfect
this is it and they focused a lot on
singing which is something that I enjoy
and so it was it seemed like the perfect
fit and so I begged my parents to go
there and when went there I did
experience a little bit of a reprieve
from my struggles okay um and that was
because I for the first time in my life
I had you know really good friends and I
didn't I was able to be out of that very
conservative household but I can imagine
that in this conservative situation
there's probably still no talk about
sexuality see that's the Ming key cuz
the structure is there but the
conversation isn't and so just a level
of suppression you have all the great
elements but don't know what to do with
what's inside right yep so at that
particular point in time what was your
communication like with God so that's
that's the interesting thing so since I
was let's see about 10 years old I have
always had a relationship with God and
it's been back and forth um for example
in later years as I'm driving to a
hookup you know I'd be talking to God
like upset with him but I I have always
talked with him and it started with I
had this intense fear of the dark and so
I would talk to God and then that would
help me asleep and so it it worked and
so through that I developed a friendship
with him so while I was at the uh
Academy the boarding Academy there was a
lot of I was looking through my my my uh
prayer journaling the other day and I
was actually looking and seeing how it
kind of made me a little bit sad but
also I guess not sad because I was
talking to God and carrying those things
to him but I was just expecting him to
take this struggle from me and so I was
reading through that there's a lot of
pain but also Beauty in that I was
communicating with him him in that you
know I for all of the time that I've
been in Ministry and looking at this
from a different perspective an ex gay
perspective you know I hear so many
people we all prayed the same prayer you
know God please take this away yeah and
you know and I share with people today
you know God is not a genie you know if
if he gave us everything that we asked
for you know what would be the you know
that wouldn't make him God because he
knows better yeah but that that
sometimes God allows things to occur to
show that we need to have a Reliance and
a dependence upon him and you know that
can happen as a result of any addiction
whether it's food or alcohol or you know
something else but
um it's it's
interesting I think for people who were
blessed in a Christian environment you
have a connection there and that I'm so
glad that God doesn't give up on us yeah
and he does and he doesn't Force he
allows us to come into a time where we
we engage with him and develop that
intimacy with him yeah and I and I would
like to say just backpedal a little bit
um I told how how my parents definitely
there was some flaws in the way that
they raised us kids but at the same time
there's flaws in all of us right we we
all make mistake and fall short so but
the one thing going back to the
relationship ship with God like you're
talking about that is the single
greatest thing that they have had taught
me and that was they taught all of my
siblings that is the importance of a
relationship with God so where they fell
short if we relied on God we would be
able to get through and so I'm very
appreciative of that I can imagine that
people who are specifically raised
Christians who pray that prayer God
please take it away and God
doesn't like from you guys experience
how do you deal with that do you get
angry at God does it feel unfair like to
me if I were your position i' be like
but you made Adam and Eve and and you
know you said like they it's not good
for man to be alone and if you choose to
which you guys have to not live that
lifestyle anymore and you don't get an
attraction for women again which we know
um uh what's his name um your former
cooworker he's now married right uh Ron
Wy Ron woy he did experienced that but
1% of the xay population marry you know
exactly how do how do you guys do that
it is frustrating because but but I have
to look back at the idea uh and the
realization that this was brought on by
the enemy this is something that that
was is the result of sin and there are
times because of the and you know I can
already tell well we can talk more about
it you know because the postcon
conversion experience you know people
expect you like people approach me today
and go oh do you have a girlfriend are
you married and I'm like
you know that's the conversion wasn't to
replace my sexual appetite it was to win
my heart to to be on the S side of
Christ that I would be willing to deny
myself for Christ and you tell somebody
today that they are not going to have
sexual activity that's like a death
sentence yeah and and also for somebody
who lived in the depths of of
homosexuality that I did 40 Years of
which was quite promiscuous you know
even to the point of of male
prostitution you come out of that
remember you know Jesus wasn't in charge
of me making those negative
decisions but I bear the scars of those
things and so yes God and we know that
God will for some people who have been
smokers and they pray and say Lord would
you just take this away and God takes it
away and other people every time a
cigarette is lit they want one but that
person to whom God took it away
maybe they have really bad financial
issues in their lives and they need to
be more regimented in their accounting
and and not be uh impulsive Spenders or
whatever there's certainly another
challenge that God know is still allowed
in their lives whereas I think the most
key and the most uh predominant in my
life you know has been the same-sex
attraction and and where that can go if
I allow it I I need Jesus constantly
yeah daily and well minutely hourly but
so t for when who well not who but when
was your first one-on-one encounter and
what did that do and how did you feel as
it related to to your experience with
God yeah so let me bring it up from
where we were when I was in Academy so I
uh graduated from that and then like I
said went to a very conservative Bible
College as well and while there I still
was not looking at I guess you would say
hard pornography I was looking at things
you know I was looking at men in the
wrong way or thing you know different
magazines in the doctor's office or
things like that but I wasn't looking at
hard pornography in in part because I
had you know restrictions on my phone
that I had placed or were placed there
when I was in Academy from the school or
my parents or things like that so I had
still not looked at that which I am
grateful that it took a that it was that
long that I didn't look at pornography
yeah but once I graduated from uh was
actually I think it was while I was in
Bible College I went on a vacation with
family and I remember looking at
pornography and then that's when it
clicked in my head like this is not just
a struggle that's going to go away this
is something you know in my mind I was
like I'm gay and it just like sent like
shivers down my spine because while also
being at these conservative acms and
schools and things like that in that in
those circles you hear a lot about the
lgbtq community and so for so long IID
said that's not me that's not me that's
not me and then having all of those
accusations all those things like that
is me and so that was a really tough
time and um I would look at pornography
off and on but I wasn't addicted to it
it would you know I'd stop I'd pray you
know recommit and things like that but
then after after my uh time at the Bible
College when I started working and I
started working in a Ministry and so and
so it was great I enjoy and I praise the
Lord that I never my struggles never
collided with the ministry so there was
never any scar in that way with what I
was able to do and work with the Lord in
that way but that being said I was
living a double life I was started
looking at more pornography I became
addicted to it and then pornography was
not enough and so then I decided to move
into you know different things meeting
up with people hookups and stuff like
that and yeah that was about when I was
to and during that time I would imagine
the the the addiction begins to be
rather overwhelming yeah and the and
usually when you when a person or when I
engaged in in that aspect of
sexuality there there isn't a closeness
to God because you when you do what the
enemy has coerced you into doing or
suggested that you do the natural Resort
result of that is is guilt and the the
enemy's messages to you are God doesn't
want anything to do with you now you've
screwed up man you're nothing you're
you're you're a failure and so and then
how does the addict cope with that more
pornography more more the addiction a
catch 22 Yeah well when you you when you
were telling your story you said you
found affirmation within the gay
community and then you you went fullon
into it
toer I don't know if you canate to that
finding a level of AFF the community
even though it was hidden to um you know
your job and whatever else was going in
your life what was it that kept you in
that doubleness instead of just going
full on straight in so I always knew
that it was wrong like I cannot I've
seen too much from the Bible I've read
too much and I have too much of a walk
with God to to just throw it away I I
know where it leads it's just I did not
know how to deal with
all of the pain the struggle and and the
same seex attraction I didn't know how
to deal with it and going back to your
question I didn't know how to deal with
that either you know like why why do I
have to struggle with this all my life
you know and so it's not fair and
somebody else doesn't yeah and so that
that is what you know kept me going kind
of like in a limbo stage it's
interesting that um the same struggle is
happening within the context of a
talking broadly positive influence and
then a negative influence but you have
two people you know with that with that
that similar struggle wow so so then
what the common denominator then that
that brought you both where you are now
is that personal relationship with Jesus
like doesn't matter which way you're
you're influenced it's not until the
individual has now that personal
connection with Christ that the heart
transformation happens would you say
that's the
case yes I think and I would you I'd
like to hear from you um um as you
engaged in the Random Encounters and and
at some point in that a person more
likely for somebody who has a Christian
background who has been blessed with the
teachings of the Bible you know comes to
a place of
contemplation and says I think that if I
if I understand the word correctly and I
look at my trajectory or my
destiny this doesn't work out well if I
continue to self- indulge or live
according to my feelings would was that
your experience at what point would you
have decided that I rather than
continuing in a vein of continue hookups
or meeting people I'm going to choose
Jesus fulltime well it took a little bit
of a deeper turn before it got there I I
decided you know what the hookups are
not enough I need romantic yeah um and
so then I switched rather than just
looking for Speedy hookups I started
looking for um romantic a romantic
partner and so um I found who I thought
was the guy that I wanted you know he
everything he checked all the boxes and
so it was coming back from visiting him
one day and I just could not stop crying
in the car and I was just like you know
kind of yelling at God angry and because
one step every step I had taken it
didn't bring any more peace happiness or
fulfillment you know so starting with
the masturbation the pornography the
hookups and now the Romantic uh
connection it still wasn't fulfilling
and I just wanted to get back to where I
was with God in the past when I was less
addicted to to certain things when I had
more freedom from that kind of stuff and
so even though I wasn't trying to I
didn't want to necessarily get away from
the the struggle I just wanted to get
back to God because I my relationship
with God had definitely gotten worse
while I was doing the hookups because
but you were still talking to God I was
still talking to him but it became very
focused on self very focused on why are
you doing this to me and um it wasn't as
much of a two-sided relationship with
with God to understand your thought
process you're calling it a struggle now
were you also calling it a struggle back
then or were you kind of confident in
what you were doing you just wanted that
relationship with Christ I was I still
considered it a struggle okay I never
have considered myself gay and even when
I would go on these romantic dates they
were I would I would lie to the people
um that I was going on dates with the
guys and I would um tell them that I was
in the lifestyle because you know I
didn't want them to think that I was
closeted or something like that but as
soon as I left and and wouldn't spend
time with them I would just be you know
crying upset with God so T far I you
know that brings up an excellent point
because nowhere in the Bible do you see
somebody you know describing somebody as
gay in fact you don't see anywhere that
God is describing somebody as
heterosexual and so so in the church
today you know I there are many people
from the outside well actually from the
inside too that would still say well
he's still gay you know but the fact
that you have same-sex attraction or the
fact that you are tempted or the fact
that you have a past does not determine
your identity in Jesus Christ your
identity comes from who he says that you
are and you know and that takes me you
know to 1 Corinthians again 69 10 and 11
we never used to hear about verse 11 you
know which says such were some of you
and not such are some of you yeah and
then 2 Corinthians 5:17 that says you
know if you surrender yourself and live
you know choosing to live for Jesus
Christ that you become a new creation in
him and I would challenge any viewer you
know even if you fell to pornography
last night and you have been a Christian
your whole life you still have that
opportunity with Jesus Christ to say I'm
sorry please remove move me from this
environment please help me get rid of
these things in my life and I accept
that I am a new creation in Jesus and
you know that's to somebody on the
outside or who is really in the depths
of homosexuality you know maybe that
sounds kind of corny but it is a truth
and it is in God's word and you know
everybody is looking for somebody to
believe in or follow today even in the
uh LGBT narratives and all the other
look at the both the Republican and and
and the Democratic Society today they're
always looking for somebody to follow
and and I can say that in my life the
most reliable person to follow is Jesus
Christ and I like everything that he has
you know to offer me and I see that
there it's a collision course because
there are things along the way that will
be placed there as boulders to make me
stumble yeah yeah so uh Turning Point
how long did you did you just have one
romantic relationship and say that's
enough it was just one yes prise the
Lord for that yeah and it was and and
that's when I on the way back I I had
called my my uh close friend and was
just crying and she was able to
encourage me and from then on I was like
okay I have to be all in because this
this struggle is is too much and so I
decided to you know I need to stop
hiding in the hiding in the darkness and
stuff like that so I started telling
people um throughout the throughout the
time I just started telling people about
my struggles my close friends family and
through that I've been able to develop
so so I was going to say so you it's not
like you were coming out of the closet
as people say you were actually you were
not saying I am gay you were saying I
have these struggles but I want Jesus
yes that's amazing so it was very weird
and depending on the the the friendship
and where they were in their
relationship with God some of them
thought I it was coming out because they
they don't see someone can live with the
samesex attraction but still follow
Christ or even have no problem with you
you all you just need to accept yeah
yeah there's a lot that out there too
yeah so it was it was interesting and so
I I don't live in denial yeah so I
started sharing with with people um
those things and then I really just I
was like I have to do something I have
to find some Community have to to to
find that and so I reached out actually
to an individual who I saw on uh a
YouTube video and it was really a great
ministry and so I was able to contact
him he put me in contact with as well as
encouraging you know me himself he put
me in contact with different Bible study
groups with different U men's groups
both ones that with people struggling
with same sex attraction but also those
who just struggle with sexual addiction
in general and so through those groups
through um mentoring Through the Bible
through Jesus himself helping me I've
been able to uh be able to lay aside
different things that Aid in that
struggle um and one of those being I
talked to you earlier about my social
media account I had quite a following uh
over 300,000 between my accounts yeah
tell me what you do aside from the the
being same seex attracted what is your
livelihood as a man yeah so so I own a
small private zoo I do educational
programming for libraries schools like
that that's so cool it's a petting zoo
right petting zoo kind of it's more of
an educational Hands-On interactive but
you can call it petting too yeah that's
cool I wish I could play with goats all
day yeah so you you that's a quite a um
you know a self-defined a business that
is going to rely largely on social media
and yet in your Christian experience you
decide that rather than engaging in
social media where I know that could
provide a a major stumbling block and
cause me to have constant failures yeah
what do you do yeah so that was besides
surrendering my sexuality to God fully
after I told you about that one romantic
encounter I had um I I decided you know
what I have to do you know find figure
out what's what's my stumbling block and
it turns out you know social media was
because I had this following the
affirmation that guys were giving me on
there and I was so were you openly gay
no no I was on my social media account
it was about animals educational things
and I would even talk about God on there
but men would approach you yes in the
DMS yep that's so interesting cuz you
would wonder I mean I think it's the
devil I think he was yeah because like I
mean all of us have had social media
mean it's not like women approach me all
of a sudden you know like so I wonder
why that happened so that has to create
a lot of challenges what happened to
your business yeah so I I shifted my
business to being less on there and the
truth is I was making more money in the
physical real world not related to the
social media um and so I was like you
know I was making a bit on there but I
decided it was taking too much time
anyways so all in all it was a good
decision but it hurt like it besides
turning my sexuality to Christ it was
the second most difficult thing that
I've had surrender to him because I mean
I like the affirmation I liked the the
notoriety that I was getting on there
and so um having to surrender that and I
don't know it was this past February I
don't know if I'll get back on there and
make videos in the future all I know is
right now I want to focus more on my
relationship with God Amen and then you
know if he if he directs me there then
he directs me there back onto it so
you're you know my mom told me when I
was I don't know you're a biological mom
no because I never I never you know once
you're adopted at two and a half years
old your aunt and uncle are you're never
going to know them as your aunt and
uncle they're your parents so I you know
they yeah my my mom which some would
think as my aunt would tell me that oh
well when you get older you know that
the sensuality thing will all fall off
and you won't have to worry about that
anymore I was I was really looking
forward to that day well I'm still
looking forward to it because it it it
doesn't really go away and so I I find
that the the challenge is is constantly
there and you know
the the real focus in my life has to be
Jesus and so to anyone who is
watching who is listening to both you
and I on this tell me what what is it
that Jesus has that would want that
would give you this impression that you
should give up everything that
potentially could make you happy H so
for me it was the peace that he offers I
had no peace um in any of the times that
I was pursuing
homosexuality and that's probably the
the biggest thing I mean
yeah and you're just because you made a
decision for Jesus Christ didn't mean
that your samesex attraction went away
correct yeah so it's it's a struggle I
mean it but every sin is a struggle
right we're all called to
you know laid at the foot of Jesus every
day so to the to the person who
identifies as LGBT says well then come
on then you know why why do you keep
going down this road I mean if that's
how you feel because today people tell
you to go with your gut be who you
are if if if who you really are is gay
then why not be gay because it's worth
the struggle the peace the love and the
joy that I get from Christ and his
followers and choosing to pursue him
rather than a homosexual life is far
greater and it outweighs the the
struggle of of uh dealing with samesex
attraction so so I have a question so
there there might be people watching who
are living in an lgbtq life who might be
in relationships who say they're happy
mhm right and so my my question is
because I believe true happiness only
comes through Jesus Christ and not
living in
sin how how do you answer that like are
would you just say to them well you're
not actually truly happy or you have you
know lived up to this kind of
understanding of what happiness is
supposed to be but there's all of this
that you haveen an experience in Jesus
how how do you answer that especially
when the alternative is linked to a
traumatic experience yes or or or they
might say you know again like well I'm
happy now in my relationship but the
alternative is being single you know so
when I speak to congregations I ask the
question can Satan make you happy and
it's always get mixed answers you know
usually people are like no but but yeah
Satan can make you happy at least you're
what what is your definition of
Happiness so if your definition of
happiness is to be content and plated
you know right here on this Earth for
right now you can get that but it's only
for this Earth it's certainly not going
to go into eternity you know or do are
you
contemplating you know if I'm going to
contemplate a life that doesn't end then
I want to look at the what the the um
qualifications or what the definitions
of that is and I'm only going to find
that out from diving into God's word and
studying God's word and then the Holy
Spirit as a teacher will help me
recognize that um my true value is in
who Jesus says that I am rather than you
know somebody who who is is just making
me feel good and often in relationships
even in heterosexual relationships today
there can be a lot of focus on
self-gratification and not so much
gratification to or honoring of the the
feelings of that other person and so
it's it can what what the whatever the
enemy can do on a temporary basis to
Sidetrack you from from what God's real
intent for you is you know is is what a
danger that's out there what do you
think toer I think everyone is on a
journey and I think if they're watching
in this and they see that there's
probably something in you know the
viewer that is making them Wonder like
is there something more is there
something different and so I think that
if they're genuinely seeking to live the
best life that they can if they open
themselves up to the idea and
potentially a conversation with god then
I think he will show and he will provide
a way for them to to uh to have a more
fulfilling life when they surrender to
him you know would so would you say that
you're a gay Christian no why not
toer because you have same seex
attraction so you know wouldn't that be
part of your identity I well I think you
know anything with a label I don't like
so um but especially that label because
there's so much that comes along with it
um I I'm a Christian first and foremost
I'm a child of God and then do I
struggle with same attraction yeah do I
struggle with Envy yeah do I struggle
with all these different things but I'm
not going to take my struggle and name
it in the beginning of my Christianity
so what if I that's interesting so a
friend told me this thing like what if
if you struggled with stealing are you
going to call yourself a Christian a
stealing Christian I'm not going to do
that I firmly believe homosexuality is a
sin and it's my struggle I'm not going
to put it right up there in line with my
walk with God that's so interesting like
you're not taking your sin and your
struggles as like this is just who I am
and this is my identity you're saying my
identi is in Christ and like I agree
with you the same thing is like like if
I had a problem with stealing I'm like
I'm a thief and I want to be a thief for
the rest of my life because I struggle
with this with stealing I I've never
heard that way before and that's really
powerful so we could go down the road of
queer Theory which is being you know
highly promoted today um in both in and
outside Church environments and I I find
in queer Theory there still is this um
hanging on to self and promoting self
over who Christ says that I am and so
while that's it's that's actually
another conversation that we can save
for a different day but I think it's
really important to to um immerse myself
in Jesus Christ and who he says that I
am but that being
said what about the LGBT person who
walks into a a church
congregation and you know it's I had a
re can walk into a church congregation
and nobody knows anything whereas
somebody who's
LGBT they they're scrutinized and um
there's a lot of critical um thoughts
that come or suspicions or you can feel
like an eyesore almost immediately was
that your experience when you came back
into the church those three months in
fact I believe now that you know I tell
audiences today that where I've spoken
over years that there might be somebody
in another denomination today I mean
another church today that says oh what's
the name of that guy you know that guy
that came and talked to us you know that
gay guy so they won't probably remember
me as a being a new creation in Christ
but they'll always I'll have the Scarlet
Letter forever is what it generally
feels like and even in you know after 15
years of being in an XK Ministry I still
know that when I'm in church
environments most of the time I'm
different than everybody else
what what do you think you know let's
talk about that for the few minutes that
we have left about how to embrace an
individual and make them feel that
they're part of God's family and that
they that we're we're definitely all
Sinners but often I hear that people say
that it's an excuse we're all Sinners so
we can just be the way that we are I
would rather see it from the standpoint
that yes we're all Sinners but we should
be able to walk with each other and help
each other along the way yeah wow that's
a heavy question yeah I I I do know from
my experience when I worked in the
ministry I was telling you about while
you know acting out outside of it that
it was a struggle because I knew that if
I shared my struggles with anyone you
know what they would think because I
hear you know you hear what people say
you hear what they say about you know
people that struggle with samesex
attraction whether they enter their
lifestyle or not and you know it is that
Scarlet Letter like you're saying so
that also aided in my pain and in me not
sharing with anybody just like more and
more isolating to myself is because I'm
like they're going to be like hide your
kids hide your you know this is yeah
they they see it very differently a lot
of people not everybody but majority of
people see this sin as something that is
different and somehow worse or scarier
than other sins but in your testimony
you made a pretty radical decision uh
when you said no I'm I'm I'm going to
actually start telling people about this
my close friends family what have you
what was it about them that made you
comfortable to share it and how can that
be influ by the church so I was I was
meeting with this group and I was
talking to this one guy and he was
really encouraging me I really looked up
to him he had lived in the lifestyle for
a long time and he has not he was now a
pastor and so he was he was very
encouraging he's like you know
encouraging me to talk to people he's
like it must be lonely you have to be so
lonely you should tell people it might
bring healing if you talk to your family
it might all these different things and
so I was like no there's no way I can't
tell anybody I'm not going to do this at
all and then finally I decided to tell I
don't want to get a I might get
emotional with this part but I was like
finally I was like okay I will tell
somebody I'll tell one person and it
happened to be this older lady that I
highly looked up to and she was the
first person that I was going to tell
and I and I told
her and I remember when she told me
she's like she's like Topher when I was
in college I was for two years I was in
a lesbian relationship and I would not
even known this about this lady at all
but then I was able to open up to her
and she was just someon for my life I'm
like what on Earth wow and so God
arranged that per perfectly so that she
would be the first person I would tell
and it gave me encouragement you know
and she was able to encourage me after
that and so I was like you know what I'm
going to tell more people it doesn't
matter what they think of me you know I
need to tell people so that so that uh
um one so if there's anyone else like me
that's was struggling they would you
know know that they're not alone because
normally in the church you only hear
about people that left it and are in the
lifestyle or they somehow are married
and or they're just like Sanctified and
they're not gay anymore or whatever and
so there's you know you don't really
hear so much much about the people that
are still struggling and so I was like
you know what I I just have to I just
have to talk I'm tired of I'm tired of
being isolated of not sharing what I
struggle with and not being able to help
in that way with possible but to make
this as practical as possible for
someone who has that desire they want to
share but they may not have those same
connections that you did is it still why
is there wisdom still behind just tell
someone or you know I think you have to
be careful and and pray about it for
sure and and what you're telling to to
be someone you trust someone you trust
yeah and so there was definitely cases
of people that I told that it didn't go
so well some family members you know and
so well how did you navigate that it was
tough but I had a support group so
because I kept praying Lord I need
people that you know because I I can't
walk this walk alone and so he was able
through different situations not always
sometimes it was like I was alone but he
gave me groups at different times that I
could share with and so this one Bible
study group they were they were really
there for me when I had some difficult
uh people that I told and so they were
there for me and they were you know
praying with me I remember they laid
their hands on me and then they were
shedding tears for me and I was crying
and it was it was just beautiful and and
it was so so uh what I needed excellent
and I think also maybe you know that's
why there are fortunately all these xgay
Ministries like Wayne's Ministries know
his love I mean can they reach out to
you if people have questions or
struggles sure absolutely so for contact
information um you can email me at No
Greater Love which is
KN just like like getting to know Jesus
no greater lovec
comcast.net you can also go to my
website which is um knis
love.org and I just want to say
something about you know Church
environments it's it's about loving
without compromise it's not something
you're going to catch and so you know
take it and invest an interest in
someone you know invite them home for
dinner and get to know them for who they
are listen to their story story um show
them that you're genuinely interested
maybe they're going to share some things
with you that are shocking but you will
you know ask the holy spirit to guide
you you don't need to shove Jesus down
their throat but you need to be a person
that is there who is available for them
who will pray with them who will walk
with them who can you know you can even
give um suggestions sometimes as you
know maybe there's a Bible study group
or there maybe there's a an outing
that's going to take place that would be
nice to keep that person involved I
might also say that this is runs the
same for single individuals in the
church that don't even identify as LGBT
because you know I remember being
younger boy if you weren't married by
the time you were like 33 years old you
know you were going to be like a an
outcast and so we we need the the family
love the God's family love to to touch
people's hearts but family love of Jesus
Christ is still in the concept that
equates to God's love and truth message
not taking exception to his word and
making provision because you know with
queer Theory today it's okay you know if
you have a consensual partner and that
you love and care about God will smile
on that well you have to show me that
from God's word and I haven't been able
to find that in God's word and I do
believe that we can trust God's word
from Genesis to Revelation yeah I I I
before we start recording I share you
guys that I know of some individuals
that perhaps have you know told uh a
family member if you do this you're
going to go to hell and I think those
people were doing it out of love they
were fearful they were like please don't
do this but I don't think that's the
right method to bring people back right
as much as you don't want to just say
well whatever it doesn't matter and
accept it I think from what you're
saying the best way to go about it is to
love that person to hold up your
Christian standards like your parents
were doing in your home but to show
kindness and love because what did Jesus
do he ate with Sinners right he went
into their home if he had a home I bet
you he would invite them into his home
and he was like I'm just showing you my
love will you accept it right I also
think that the responsibility is on both
sides like as as much as the church has
dropped the ball and this is something
we all deal with as as humans not just
um people in the in the gay community as
as someone in the lifestyle who is
wanting to come out is approaching the
church there's all these preconceived
ideas and doubts and fears there so now
any anyone in the church who does
anything it's oh they must be doing it
because of this or because they see me
like this or anything like that and
there's a lot of selft talk dangerous
selft talk that can impede the process
of the church actually showing as much
love as they can to that person yeah and
and you're going back you know said it's
two-sided it definitely is because the
devil is active and he wants to keep you
out of you know communication with
people that are going to you know be
that great community that you need
they're going to offer that that
spiritual mentorship and all that kind
of stuff and so if if you're a viewer
and and you're someone that struggles
with anything or you know with samesex
attraction if you're if you're trying to
find that community that God you know
would have you be a part of you know you
have to push past different things
someone might offend you you know you
have to see it like yes it's annoying
they're doing that but behind that
there's a great controversy the devil is
the one that's you know influencing that
cuz he wants to keep you away from the
church he wants to keep you out yeah so
in a church environment there's going to
be a wide body of responses today and um
sadly to say I'd be willing to Guess
that probably 50% of the church
membership is going to affirm you and
tell you oh that's fine it's not a
problem you know everybody is welcome
here so when you begin if you're
identifying as LGBT and you really are
seeking Christ make sure that you really
are seeking him through his word and
that his word is always true and that
you may encounter people within the
church that are going to try to affirm
you in your attractions but you might
even be a witness to them by saying you
know I really don't think that's how God
is asking me to live I think God is
asking me to live according to his
precepts and his promises and nowhere
throughout God's word are we given an
example of a same gendered relationship
intimate relationship that God approved
of and he calls us to deny ourselves and
surrender ourselves to Jesus and to walk
with him and not to have the slightest
hint of sexual immorality in our lives
so keep those things in alive alive in
your mind while you are seeking out
people who you want to socialize with or
to engage with um I think it's very good
for somebody who's LGBT to get involved
in a Bible study group um that is you
know that is wanting to live in a
agreement with God's word if you're uh
you can you know get in touch with me
get in touch with to for four um uh
there are accountability groups that
finally today that people can talk that
are like-minded that are or are
experiencing struggles and difficulties
you know a c a shoulder to cry on you
know to say I really need help through
this you know can I come here can I talk
to you guys you know there's far more
available today than there used to be
and and you know on another
um program you know we'll talk more
about the different positions there are
within the church um on this today but I
think this is a great start for somebody
who's identifying as LGBT as well as a a
welcoming home family what is your pris
on churches having
intentional intentional groups for for
those coming out the LGBT community for
example some people within the church
have problem with AA because AA is like
you're always calling yourself alcoholic
um so they have women's ministry there's
men Ministries and all that should there
be a a um what would you call it xgay
yeah ex gay Ministry like was that
beneficial or or not in the church
context there's probably different
different opinions on this um I remember
when I first came back to Christ and and
there was someone within the church says
yeah give him the Fireside room he can
minister to all the gay people and I was
like my Ministry was not then was
wouldn't be good for me like I don't
need to go like back into bars to start
drinking or hooking up or to gay baths
or something like that I I need in an
environment to be woven into the church
body so that I am I like I do need a
men's group and when before I moved here
to Tennessee I was in a men's group that
was heterosexual and I was the one who
had had same-sex attraction and they
allowed me to share and and then they
shared and really at the core of it all
it was you know addiction and and doing
things that were not good for us and so
it was good in that environment I know
that there are um and there are specific
groups that are are good for same-sex
attraction you might be able to speak to
that yeah there there definitely are
some and probably in in uh larger cities
there are some but in rural areas you
know if there's small churches or things
like that you know people are probably
going to have to join a group where it's
for example like you said it was all in
that group you were in it's all
heterosexual and you were the only one
that had samesex attraction I'm also
part of a group that's similar like that
there's a couple of us that struggle
with samesex attraction but the majority
it's more heterosexual sexual addictions
and so um so in that one I found a lot
of of comfort as well as a lot of uh of
healing and growth through that group
which I was so surprised I was scared to
join it at first but I think people have
to be open to the idea it's like I just
need someone that's I just need someone
that's came in the lifestyle I came out
of Lifestyle they're going to help me
and blah blah blah but you know God can
use anybody and so that group that I'm a
part of that's all those guys they're
some of the greatest guys out there like
they're they're so supportive and
helpful and you know a lot of that shame
is is gone now because of how much go
God's love they've shown to me so it's
pretty neat and it's good to be able to
bounce ideas of that are working things
that are working for people um you know
in relationship with their walk with God
and things that will help them to keep
them away from addictive habits or or if
they do have failure somebody that they
can call and say Hey you know I'm a mess
and somebody that you can pray with and
yeah and without divulging all of that
to to you know people that might take
and run with that you know in that
aren't so familiar with the topic yeah
Topher if the if somebody wanted to
reach out to you is there uh do you have
an email or something that you might be
able to share yes it's Critter brain
gmail.com so it's a good one it's see r
i TT r b r a i n gmail.com great and I
you know I just want to encourage people
that um you know without Jesus I say you
can do whatever you want so to the
Skeptics you know you have the freedom
to be a skeptic you have the right to be
critical if you want but if you're
engaged as somebody who is has been
struggling with the LGBT ideations and
you believe in God you know God is not
going to leave you stranded yeah that he
wouldn't be God and so you know get in
touch or be assured that you know he
loves you he's not letting go and I've
had screw-ups even since I've come back
to Christ and I'm I'm so glad that God
doesn't abandon us and you know engage
in the conversation with Jesus you know
talk to him and allow him um to have a
place in your life and to be the leader
of your life and he will bring you peace
and he will bring you Joy amen well
thank you Wayne and toer for joining us
I think this was an awesome conversation
I really hope it will be helpful to you
guys at home uh whether you in the lgbtq
community whether you are or know
someone who is so that's the episode for
today LED live make sure you hit
subscribe hit the notification Bell so
you know about upcoming episodes we're
here every single week on LA Live and uh
make sure you hit a comment below
because it helps to get the M out to
more people also we've got t-shirts
we're not wearing them today but you can
find them on lightwear do shop where you
can wear your witness with awesome
Christian t-shirts we've got a podcast
season 2 is being uploaded as we speak
every single Sunday uh on uh wherever
you listen to your podcast uh Little
Light Studios podcast we dive into deep
and challenging Bible questions make
sure you hit subscribe to that too and
other than that uh if oh if want to
donate you can donate as well to our
ministry uh L.T v/g or
patreon.com Ed Studios that's it for
today and we'll see you guys next week
bye bye
[Music]
I'm sorry do we know each other it seems
like maybe we've met before I don't know
this is uh it's awkward though just as
much for me as it is for you I really
wish I had a conversation
[Music]
starter oh hey oh what's on my shirt and
this is the story of the Three Angels
message from Revelation 14 wow that
totally worked you know if you have
trouble starting conversations like me
maybe you should try like where
[Music]